hier soir le sénateur du rassemblement
national des Bouches-du-Rhône Stéphane
Ravier était l'invité de Ruth Elkrief
sur LCI
mets sur la polémique du président de la
République Emmanuel Macron qui avait
déclaré la veille avoir très envie
d'emmerder les nouvelles cela fait 4 ans
qu'il nous emmerde
à l'écart des autres invité sur le
plateau et
[Musique]
sur les réseaux sociaux
merci Stéphane Ravier d'être avec nous
sénateur de rassemblement national hier
on vous a mis à l'écart vous ai dit
tu dégages
ça me fait plaisir de vous revoir
à l'occasion et bien
sûr que l'on tu m'as pas mis à l'écart
lorsque j'étais dans les coulisses on a
pas trouvé
dangereux que j'approche de la de la
maquilleuse que j'approche d'autres
invités c'est uniquement sur le plateau
là peut-être que c'était pour protéger
surtout madame d'accord tu tu pensais
que ça
allait
[Musique]
Louis
du rassemblement national et je ne suis
pas
mais je trouve que ça
devient n'importe quoi
donc voilà
il me traite comme un souci toi il m'a
dit il m'a dit que j'étais plus un
citoyen
c'est qu'il allait nous emmerder
non je
suis reposé
et la pire j'ai voulu montrer aux
Français en général au 5.000 en
particulier la manière dont c'est traité
aujourd'hui
et les Français séparés alors pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas fatigué
donc vous n'êtes pas gentil va pas
depuis depuis que depuis que je suis né
mais celui-là je le sens pas envie j'ai
pas
encore de cette liberté
ou pas
[Musique]
je n'aurai plus les mêmes droits que les
50 autres million de Français je suis
sous citoyen je suis traitée quand même
pas rien alors j'ai moins de droits que
les autres parce que je ne veux pas être
vacciné c'est une république vaccinal
que Emmanuel Macron est à monter une
république vaccinal nos droits sont
conditionnés à partir de 2h ou pas
d'être vacciné c'est extrêmement grave
alors qu'il est le garant de la
Constitution c'est-à-dire que l'égalité
des citoyens devant la loi
pour ceux qui
[Rires]
ne sont pas recevable il fallait il
fallait pas venir je ne me plains pas
il y a au moins
j'aurais pu très bien pu être à côté de
Monsieur le la distance et respecté avec
un masque mais vous avez anticipé
manifestement ce que souhaite Emmanuel
Macron où vous l'avez trop bien compris
en traitant les non vacciné comme des
pestiférés est quoi c'est horrible mais
est-ce que c'est ce qui a été fait avec
Fabrice
respecter la loi
celui qui ne compte
pas parce que je ne veux pas tomber dans
le piège dans lequel Emmanuel Macron a
déjà fait tomber
du gouvernement
et qui est
en faisant porter la responsabilité
traduis je termine par une opposition
une une division entre les Français
c'est ça que je veux